Mr doc winner is here what's up so DOC
for people who don't know yeah what's
your title I'm the president of hip-hop
and R B programming strategy for I heart
and program director real 92.3 issue
Braille 92.3 yeah
click up on the mic a little bit a
little bit on the mic we gotta start
over are we good no you're good you're
good um so
uh
uh big title we've made plenty of uh of
like the source power 30 list and you've
I mean you're here a very very important
guy in the music industry I gotta thank
you because you've given me opportunity
after opportunity
um well we launched real
um I got a bunch of audition tapes yeah
to this day yours was still the best
yeah that was like late 2014 I might
have sent that I was in Tampa yeah yeah
2015. and whack 100 called me out of
dinner with you and was like I'm with
Doc winner right now I'm telling them
about you I was like
would you say
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so at that
point in time I called a bunch of
rappers and I was like I need you guys
all to do a drop that says bring bootleg
head to La yeah that was good man and it
worked it's just Los Angeles man bring
bootleg Kev to Los Angeles do it for me
yo man you gotta bring bootleg cab to
L.A bring bootleg Kev to La he deserves
it man tell him I said Ty Dollar Sign
risking my life right now I'm pushing
the label Taylor Gang that died
to Los Angeles right now man yo what's
going on man it's your boy kid ain't
telling you there's no other option I'm
gonna keep it 100 and bringing my boy
bootleg cabs to Los Angeles man got to
see my brother out here in the city man
and he always keeps it to the streets
that's what I'm about
I know bring bootleg Camp to L.A
he won't admit it but he hates him he
told me many times all right so the
question is Kevin Gates admitted to
sleeping with his cousin for about two
years he was doing this he's not ashamed
of it I want to know anybody out there
have you ever hooked up with a family
member AAA 4290-94 one yeah my sister
she actually had sex with our second
cousin so it's still pretty
[Music]
meeting him for two years oh your your
sister's a dirty dirty little girl
was the family like very uh outspoken
against it or did the family like not
care no
[Applause]
no it would appear that you belong to a
family of rednecks
uh Magic Mike it's called Magic Mike
double XL if I were to be in Magic Mike
if we're talking strictly Johnson sizes
I would be in Magic Mike medium
you set low expectations so when they
see it they're like oh oh it's much
bigger than I thought and now the
thought State of the Union on the
bootleg Kev show
to say hello to
load of this Quartz in denial we are two
weeks into the most important time of
the year this time last week I know some
of you were celebrating after the Super
Bowl not because your team won but
because you may or may not have ended up
in bed with an NFL superstar some of you
even went as far as showing off your
thought accolades on Tinder shouts to
Jolene Edelman
coming to a close in Los Angeles you
gotta let your sights be set on what I
like to call the thoughty Pippin
Invitational AKA NBA All-Star Weekend in
New York City Now's the Time turn those
chic shoes high heels into red bottoms
and that tired ass Forever 21 shirt into
a brand that's hard to pronounce in the
coming days I'd like to encourage all my
thotiana Ali's step up the thirst traps
on the gram your DMs are home base and
we want as many millionaires to slide in
them as possible
so have your turkey basters ready poke
some holes in them condoms and hit New
York City this weekend whether it's an
NBA player rapper or a drug dealer
they're gonna trick their money out on
someone this all-star weekend
ask yourself this why not you
thank you very much
exclusive interviews yo it's wild 94.1
the bootleg cab show I told y'all I had
a special guest calling in I wasn't
lying we got my dog on the phone right
now Big Sean what's up player what's up
player what's up dog me shout out to you
man okay cause you my dog man you've
been holding me down for years man one
of the few people who was on it early
and just respecting it and showing real
love man so I appreciate you I'm glad
everything's going well for you yeah man
I already down there in Tampa trying it
up man so that's what it is hey I saw it
uh today
um Wiz and Amber it's official that
they're getting divorced you just went
through a public breakup you and Wiz are
super close
yeah man it's all over TMZ she filed for
divorce um so I mean is there any advice
you would give to to your big homie Wiz
I know you guys toured together uh and
you guys have been making music together
for a very long time they filed for
divorce today yeah man
I know man like bro such really good
people it sucks you know what I'm saying
because I I'm really you know close to
Wiz and it just is unfortunate but
you've been through like you know a
public breakup that that people kind of
kind of saw from the public side is
there any advice you would give to Wiz
yeah let me tell you something about
whiz is like one of my best friends
right he comes to my house frequently I
mean probably like last week maybe two
weeks ago he was at my crib he just came
over running out knocked on the door I'm
in my room on the balcony he like comes
through just talking to me about like
life I'm not saying I knew what was
coming or what wasn't coming but the
fact that that happened was just really
crazy man but you know my advice I mean
I'm not gonna blast anybody else's
business but right that's my dog and he
knows I love him so it is what it is but
that's for real that's for real my bro
right there though
[Music]
no mediocre I don't want no mediocre no
I was gonna say uh I heard that you also
might be working on some sort of cooking
show how would TI prepare a nice bowl of
Top Ramen is there anything special you
would do to the ramen noodles I've been
to prison okay and nobody will cook a
pack of noodles like me absolutely
sometimes people put like the butter you
put the hot sauce in there I don't know
exactly how to do it okay I know exactly
how to do it the Honey damn yeah the
honey harvest season so see that's
something that I do not know I'm gonna
try that tonight dude I'm going so far
I've gone so far as being so Hood to
Crunch up bags of hot fries two let me
tell you
I will never cook or eat another pack of
noodles again